when you absolutely positively have to
have Jonah Hill for your temple picture
be prepared to pony up some major cash
the star who is in talks to appear in
writer director Matt Reeves a Batman in
an undisclosed role is reportedly
seeking a figure equivalent to twice
what the flick star Robert Pattinson
will pull down don't forget my money
variety film reporter Justin Kroll
disclosed the tip bit on Twitter
adding some context to the news that
Hill is being eyed for the role in the
Batman exactly which role that is has
been kept under wraps by Studio Warner
Brothers but it's been speculated by
many that the star could be cast as the
Riddler or the penguin
according to Kroll that this is dead
accurate crow rose so on the Jonah front
he said the offer for over a month and
besides money being a bargaining point
at one point thirty one to ten which is
wild since Rob isn't making half that
but also which character he would play
whether it's the Riddler or penguin
there's quite a bit to unpack there
crawl states that Hill has been sitting
on a firm offer for more than a month
which could be taken to mean that's
while he's still technically in talks
for the role
negotiations have stalled somewhat the
reports are also asserts that at one
point Hill was asking for a whopping 10
million dollar payday to appear in the
Batman but it can be inferred that he's
not going together
if Warner Brothers were cool with
copying up its reported asking price
there would be no reason for help of
insisting on their offer for this long
understand that understand how much
money it's likely that the studio
countered with a figure more in line
with what Pattinson will be making which
Crowell says isn't even half of 10
million dollars it has to be pretty
close superheros salaries for a first
solo picture tend to fall within the
three to five million dollar range and
it's safe to say that Batman is a pretty
high-profile property by way of
comparison it's been reported that brie
Larson was paid five million dollars to
star in 2019 s Captain Marvel
more Benedict Cumberbatch pulled down
right around three million dollars to
lead 2016 s Doctor Strange we haven't
even gotten to the last part of Krauss
tweets which is perhaps the most
interesting of all apparently a major
sticking point between Hill and Warner
Brothers has to do with which character
he'll be playing which could imply that
the two parties aren't seeing eye-to-eye
on that matter
[Music]
I'm sloshed but I make million-dollar
girls
physically speaking the penguin would be
the most obvious role for hell since the
actor is relatively short of five foot
seven he lost a significant amount of
weight back in 2011 so he saw the Oswald
copper parts of the comics but he still
can't shake the fat jokes when Jonah's
agent told him to Quentin Tarantino
wanted him to be in a spaghetti western
Jonah was like you had me at spaghetti
it seems likely that the penguin is a
role that Warner Brothers has in mind
for the actor while he'll perhaps
sensitive about his weight is more keen
to take a cracker portraying Edward
nygma the Riddler
which seems like a pretty good fit to us
he'll may be known primarily for his
comedic roles but he is a gifted Academy
Award nominated actor and we can
absolutely see him bringing just the
right notes of cunning and madness to
the role of nygma Reeves has said that
he'll be fielding a more grounded noir
influence take on Batman than previous
filmmakers so while it may seem a little
on the nose to Casa comedic actor as the
Riddler Hill has proven that he has the
chops to add a bit of comedic flavor to
the role without overwhelming it it
remains to be seen how the month-long
stalemate between actor and studio will
be resolved or indeed if it will be at
all it's obvious a hill and Warner
Brothers began their negotiations pretty
far apart from what the details of the
actors contract would be and it's not
like they're on dozens of thespians in
Hollywood who would fall over themselves
for the chance to play either of the
roles Hill is reportedly being laid for
of course we'll be keeping our eyes
peeled for any developments but we'll
keep you up to speed the Batman is
expected to begin production late this
year or early next and the flick swoops
in to theaters on June 25th 2021 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos by your
favorite DC characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail said you don't miss a single
one
[Music]